[Music]
forgive me for just going back to the
first theme I want to give you one
example which I think encapsulate the
dilemma when we talk about do men have
to lose out for women to gain equality
you may have noticed this big round
weather where a woman appointed as
deputy editor in BBC News has refused to
take up the job because she was offered
a serve less I think about traditionally
12,000 less than a man the other deputy
appointed and lots of women the bieber's
he signed up in her support and they she
said same job same rate of pay the
problem is that the BBC doesn't have a
rate of pay for a job it has a band and
in that band what you get paid is
weighted also by the length of time you
spent in the organization and to agree
your age so the man she is up against
has edited number programs is 58 and so
on so in order if you take the view that
that doesn't matter it's the rate for
the job taking of the BBC of the mo what
you'll have to do is bring the man's pay
down and say there's no longer a band
for a job there's a rate but it also
means however long you do it have a
lawyer arts that company you're not
getting any more money because there is
a rate for the job that seems to me to
encapsulate a real dilemma I just wanted
to mention it because you know the way
it's report is slightly different so if
you take one view men will have to be
penalized if you take another and the
primary thing is equality of pay the pay
is the job the pay that determines it
you take another into those dilemmas
that have been fort house so I think
this issue and we see the overall issue
of women's pay at the BBC making news
headlines time and time again to me this
two shows really good illustration of
how middle-class feminism is if you work
in McDonald's and you go for a job
interview in McDonald's and you say oh
I'd like to negotiate my salary please
and I'd like my experience and I'd like
my reputation to be taken into account
there laughing you they say there's a
dog we'll get somebody else thank you if
you're a teacher even which is a fairly
middle-class job if you're a teacher and
you say I'd like to negotiate my salary
I'd like this and this to be taken into
account they say no this is the paceco
this is what you get
we've had equal pay legislation in this
country and same job same pay for many
decades since the mid 1970s and any
woman sitting in this room now if you
think that you are doing the exact same
job at the exact same level for the
exact same number of hours each week as
a man and are being paid differently
you need to seek legal redress that's
really important because you're your
employer is breaking the law and you
should go and get legal redress and I
will help you if you know make this
offer available I will do my best to
help you however when it comes to the
BBC Hollywood advertising some of these
industries that very few people work in
where where honestly I look at them and
their salaries to me look like telephone
numbers it's a salary which is way
beyond my wildest imaginings and the
wildest imaginings of everybody I know
in my family I just try to preserve
pictures then you know I'm sorry but my
heart doesn't really bleed and their
salaries are not based on the same rate
the same way in which my salary is
negotiated it's their reputation their
ability to pull in an audience they're
experienced negotiators through ages
yeah when they need to get a better age
yeah but I think you're mistaking
performance as opposed to produce this
know this because the BBC pay levels
generative count for ordinary write down
and what's happened with the
fragmentation in the industry is that
particularly and it tends been really a
lot of women are a short term contrast
salaries haven't gone up it's
casualisation that haven't been paid for
long time but no man that's the side for
more debates talks and interviews
subscribe today to the Institute of Arts
and ideas at III TV
you